Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American fantasy drama film
called “Wendy.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts in Darling’s diner owned
by a middle-aged woman named Angela Darling.
She has three kids, two twin sons, James
and Douglas, and a younger daughter,
Wendy. Their dinner lies right by a railroad
in the rural South and is always filled with
people. It is a happy and lively place where
everybody loves little Wendy. One day, a little
guy named Thomas Marshall is in the diner enjoying
a meal for his seventh birthday. His grandmother
jokes that he will be a cleaner at the diner
when he grows up. Thomas retaliates; he wants to
be a pirate but the seniors just laugh at him.
Overwhelmed with emotions, he walks outside,
when no one is watching. Little Wendy, who is
some years younger than Thomas, crawls towards
the window and watches as he gets on a moving
train. There seems to be another child on the
train with him, whose face isn’t clearly seen.
Time passes and Wendy gets older but she never
forgets what she saw that day. She becomes more
imaginative with time and often writes her own
bedtime stories about adventures. At only nine
years old, she has a thirst for adventures and is
willing to take risks for a rush of adrenaline. As
Wendy helps her mother and brothers at the diner
we see a notice on a board that says Thomas
disappeared at the age of seven and has never been
found, along with another thirteen-year-old boy,
indicating that children go missing frequently in
the town. Wendy is calm and composed in contrast
to her brothers who are always dancing, singing,
and making noise. The four of them are
a happy family nonetheless. One night,
on the boy’s demand, their mother tells them a
bedtime story about her life. She claims that she
was wild when she was younger and had dreams and
aspirations that people would make fun of her for.
She once hitchhiked to California and stole
cars on her way. Wendy is fascinated and
asks her what her dreams are now. Angela replies
that she wants to take care of her children.
She adds, as people get older and things
change, their dreams also change. This
makes Wendy sad because she never wants to give
up her dream of going on several adventures and
she doesn’t want to get old either. The following
day after school, the kids go to a canal to fish.
James and Douglas are busy when Wendy runs towards
the railway tracks. She sees a train and chases
behind it hoping to board it as Thomas did years
ago. But she falls in the way and misses it. While
returning home, she remembers her brother’s words;
Your life will go by and nothing will ever happen.
At night, everyone is asleep but Wendy keeps
herself busy by making up stories about stars.
Suddenly, a mysterious red light passes through
the window and the sound of a train approaching
is heard. She looks outside the window and sees
a boy playing and running on top of a moving
train. It is the same little boy named Peter,
who was with Thomas when he disappeared.
Wendy wakes her brothers up and climbs
out of the window to take a closer look.
The boys follow her behind but cannot
stop her before she jumps on the train.
They, too, get on board following their sister.
Wendy spreads her arms feeling free for the first
time. Then, they are approached by a laughing
Peter. The guys ask him what their stop is,
but Peter replies that there are no stops because
this is an adventure. In the morning, Peter tells
Wendy that the world has no end; it goes on and
on forever past the restaurants and the houses.
When they reach above a river, Peter asks them to
line up on the edge of the train. The kids do it
without asking any questions and yell in fear when
they are pushed into the river by him. Peter jumps
behind them and introduces them to a kid on a
boat. All of them get on the boat and sail to
the sea, eventually reaching a volcanic tropical
island. A fish-like creature from the sea makes
a noise that Peter claims is the mother welcoming
them. Seeing the magical island, Wendy remembers
the voice in her head that used to ask her to
sneak into the night. She figures that the noise
has been coming from the island all along.
An active volcano is shooting out smoke in the
air, indicating the magical charge of the place.
Peter runs into the woods with his friend,
making the siblings follow them. On their
way, they are terrorized by smoke coming out
of the ground. A while later, they meet a guy
their age singing a melody to the big volcano.
Wendy joins him out of nowhere. Peter approaches
them and says that their singing was hopeless.
He meditates and performs some hand gestures of
his own, triggering the volcano. The others run
away in fear and excitement. Suddenly, a little
boy comes running their way, who Wendy recognizes
as Thomas. Although he was older than her when
he ran away, he doesn’t seem to have aged a day.
Upon inquiry, Thomas claims that he is a
Blackbeard and runs away. At night, the other
kids play and laugh around the confused Darling
siblings. Eventually, they join the others and
start singing the same melody from earlier.
When they wake up the next morning, Peter is
looking at the sea, claiming that he is talking
to the mother. Later, he and Wendy jump into a pit
on the ground and reach a canal. Peter takes
her into the sea and shows her the mother who
turns out to be the island’s spirit in the form
of a massive fish that spreads a golden glow
wherever it goes. Peter explains that when the
first child laughed, for the first time, the
mother rose up to the surface from the center of
the earth to watch over them. She preserves their
childhood so they can go on any adventure and
do whatever they want for as long as they like.
However, the magic only works if you maintain
faith in the mother. If someone stops believing
in her, they will age at an exponential
rate and turn old. For the next few days,
life is like a movie for the children. They play,
dance, sing and laugh from day to night without
any care. Douglas and James completely forget
about their mother back home but Wendy thinks to
herself that she is just extending her visit and
will return home once she is done having fun.
One day, Wendy wakes up to see an elderly man
wandering close by. When she greets him, he runs
off into a barren side of the island. The children
explain his name is Buzzo, a former member of
their group who lost faith in Mother when he lost
his best friend, and so aged into an old man.
After that, they find a capsized boat called the
Mañana in the sea. The Darling siblings swim to
the boat to inspect it. Douglas is skeptical about
swimming into the compartments of the ship but he
agrees when James calls him a coward. The three
dive into the compartment but only James and Wendy
emerge from the other side. Worried for Douglas,
they dive back inside but are unable to find him.
The other kids also help them look but are
unsuccessful. Eventually, they drag the brother
and the sister out of water assuring them that
Douglas must be fine. Losing his twin, affects
James the most. When he wakes up the next day, his
hand has wrinkled and turned old. Wendy realizes
that James has lost faith in the mother and he
asks her to keep it a secret from the others.
However, Peter soon finds out about it. James
tries to snatch Peter’s sword to cut his old arm
off to try to stop the aging process. Peter
volunteers to do it himself and cut his arm.
Wendy runs to her brother who falls to the ground
in pain. She angrily asks everyone to get away
from them and takes James with her in search of an
actual adult. They come across Buzzo who agrees to
help them. He puts James on a donkey and takes
the two to the old people’s quarter. It is the
place where all the children who have turned into
old people live. Everyone there is catching and
killing fishes which confuses Wendy. She inquires
what they are doing to find out that eating the
mother will give old people their childhood
back, so they are trying to catch her.
James’s arm is now tied in a cloth and has stopped
bleeding. To rest, he and Wendy go to an abandoned
diner with the other old people. Silence prevails
in the room until Wendy asks everyone to bring
their childhood spirits back even if they are
old. She dances, urging the others to do the same.
Eventually, all of them get together and dance
Except for James, who is still very depressed.
He runs out in frustration as Wendy follows him
behind. James goes to the fishing zone and gets
the nets ready. The other old people see this and
decide to make him their leader because he knows
how to fish. James comes out with another plan
to capture the mother. He suggests they abduct
the children which will make the mother come to
them herself. Wendy retaliates against the idea
but the others like it. They start to prepare to
kidnap the kids while Wendy runs back to the woods
to alert them. But the adults get there before
her and kidnap all the children. The only one
that could hide and save himself is Peter. Wendy
joins him and the two watch the adults repair the
boat Mañana and board the kids on it.
Wendy notices a man with only one arm
bending a hook. It turns out that the man is
James who has grown into an adult. After they
sail away with the boat, Peter urges Wendy
to come with him and save their friends.
They jump into the ocean and end up in the canal
again. There, Peter tells Wendy about his family
back home. Wendy wanders off to the other side
of the canal to find Douglas alive and well.
The two reunite and set off to look for their
friends on a rowboat. Seeing no one on the deck,
the three of them climb up the boat and try to
untie the children, but the adults catch them
and bring them to their leader, James. He has
now turned fully old and has a hook in the place
of his missing arm. James and Douglas are both
surprised to see each other. James is mad at
him for staying young while he turned old. While
Douglas refuses to believe James is his brother.
Suddenly, the sound of the mother is heard.
The adults all prepare to hunt her while the kids
beg them to stop. They free themselves and jump
into the water to get the mother out of the net
but are too late as James strikes her with a
harpoon and injures her gravely. The golden glow
from the mother’s body dissociates and drops
to the bottom of the ocean. James manages to
get a piece of flesh from the mother’s body but
refuses to eat it at last. Peter cries in vain
about losing the mother and Wendy comforts him
by hugging him. He is worried that he will now
get old and die. Now, even makes the olds feel bad
for the kid. Wendy assures all of them that their
story is great and the bigger they get, the more
stories they can form. They can get married and
have children who will have stories of their own.
Hence, they should not be disheartened. She then
gets them to all start singing the melody again.
As their singing grows louder, Peter becomes more
inspired, and the volcano erupts once more. Wendy
and Douglas decide it is time for them to go home.
Knowing that he cannot go home, James
says his last goodbye to his twin.
He then changes his name to Captain Hook and
stays to play with Peter as his new “enemy”,
thereby allowing him to live out the rest
of his days with the spirit of a child.
In the ending monologue, Wendy says that she,
Douglas, and the other children have returned
home to their own families. They have many
adventures as they grow older. They dance and sing
and have fun even as adults. Many years later,
Wendy is now a mother with her own daughter.
She tells the story of Peter and the island to her
as a bedtime story. At night, while Wendy sleeps,
her daughter hops on the train with Peter. Wendy
runs after, but she cannot catch up to them. She
then watches them get away with a smile on her
face, knowing that her daughter is in good hands
and is ready for an adventure of her own.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.